12 people have been killed and 42
wounded this morning at two attacks in
Iran one at the national parliament one
at Ayatollah Khomeini's tomb and the
Islamic state immediately claimed
responsibility if true this would be the
first attack by Isis inside of Iran
consider that just two days ago Iran put
out a statement in response to the
London terror attacks of this past
weekend talking about how the West
should stop taking money from those who
fund terror hinting at Saudi Arabia not
to be conspiratorial but it's hard not
to notice that Iran criticizes the West
and Saudi involvement in terrorism and
then this happens and by the way almost
immediately the Islamic state releasing
a graphic video showing a bloodied man
lying on the ground in the parliament
while a gunman in the background shouts
thank God do you think we're going to
leave we will remain here God willing
suspicions in Iran are pointing to Saudi
Arabia though there was a tweet put out
earlier today indicating that Iran is
straight up blaming Saudi Arabia for
this attack if that is going to be the
direction pad this really has the
potential for significant potentially
violent escalation between
middle-eastern Muslim majority countries
yeah specially now because Isis is
losing ground when it comes to Raqqa and
Mosul and yeah as they continue to have
less land and have less legitimacy in
establishing a Caliphate you're going to
imagine that they're going to amp up
these attacks perhaps out of anger more
erratic behavior I would certainly
assume and recall that there are complex
dynamics at play here Iran supports the
Assad government in their fight against
Isis in Syria a brutal regime no doubt
that Iran is supporting and it can be
really easy to look at the region from
the US and say Oh Isis Iran and Saudi
Arabia all similar with the same
allegiances worldview and loyalties the
reality is not at all that and
infinitely more complex
that being said hamid reza taraji
a hard-line analyst with ties to Iran's
supreme leader said quote Isis
ideologically financially and
logistically is fully supported and
sponsored by Saudi Arabia and this is
actually an issue of contention we've
talked about how on the one hand Isis
and Saudi Arabia are at odds
organizationally
but that they both subscribe to
different but similar worldviews in
terms of being some of the most radical
flavors of Islam that are out there so
this is this is something that is only
starting to ramp up but then of course
the attack on Iran makes a little bit
more sense because of course Iran is
predominantly Shia yes that's absolutely
right and lots of the calling cards of
recent Isis attacks hitting more than
one location close to simultaneously
attackers having suicide vest those
vests aren't always real six attackers
were killed for the Parliament to it the
ayatollahs tomb these are the first
terror attacks in Iran in more than a
decade and Iran historically has been
both a victim of and sponsor of radical
terrorism Iran widely considered to have
been behind the attacks in my home city
of Buenos Aires in Argentina of a Jewish
organization the AMIA near were my
grandparents on my mom's side actually
lived at the time so significant
possibility of escalation in the region
a tweet this morning at 10:40 6 a.m.
Eastern saying just in Iran's
Revolutionary Guard say Saudi Arabia was
behind deadly attacks in Tehran this
could escalate and it could escalate
quickly and we were going to be paying
attention to it